how do you reconcile the fact that you
were one of the most vocal critics of
pork-barrel politics and yet while you
were chairman of the Commerce Committee
that committee set a record for
unauthorized appropriations
[Music]
just kidding steve carell the john
mccain when he was he was really trying
to figure out now how do i good senator
john mccain concluded his final book the
restless wave with a reflection on his
life of service McCain wrote I hope
those who mourn my passing and even
those who don't will celebrate as I
celebrate a happy life lived in
imperfect service to a country made of
ideals whose continued success is the
hope of the world we continue to reflect
on that life this morning with John
Dickerson on assignment in Indiana John
good morning again
good morning Anthony that life of
service according to McCain's office 60
years they noted when he passed in his
own words here's a look at how John
McCain reflected on his life legacy and
the country he loved I fell in love with
my country when I was a prisoner in
someone else's I loved it not just for
the many comforts of life here I loved
it for its decency for its faith the
wisdom justice and goodness of its
people the joy of my life was the bonds
that were forged between me and my
fellow POWs they were wonderful we
fought together we loved each other
there's no doubt that all of us were
weak from time to time there was also a
lot of courage displayed and a lot of
love for one another that I think maybe
Americans are uniquely
I'm a far better man for having had the
experience that I had I know
learned the meaning of friendship and
comradeship and love and compassion and
learned many of my own failings which
continue to this day I've been a member
of the United States Senate for thirty
years our deliberations today are often
lively and interesting they can be as
sincere in principle but they are more
partisan more tribal more of the time
than at any time that I can remember
it's necessary that even in times of
crisis we have these contests and engage
in spirited disagreement but it should
remain an argument among friends who
share an unshaken belief than in our
great cause and in the goodness of each
other we are Americans first Americans
last and Americans always my country
saved me and I cannot forget it and I
will fight for her as long as I draw
breath so help me God I want when I
leave that the ceremony is at the Naval
Academy and we just have a couple of
people that stand up and say this guy he
served his country
you know one more final line from marks
altar who you quoted earlier Nora
longtime aide of McCain's he said McCain
had the knowledge that the most
marvelous of human achievements is not
to lose hope when experience has taught
you that hope is for fools Nora thank
you John I feel like this is a really
important week because as I said kind of
earlier the passing of an era the
passing of a time there lot to be
reflective on his service the importance
of service to this country